as the merry-go-around debate over
immigration reform continues the
president on one side Republicans on the
other one thing remains constant
detention on any given day up to thirty
four thousand undocumented immigrants
are held in ice detention centers across
the United States but how much do we
really know about immigrant detention
unless you've dealt with ice chances are
very little ice is the second largest
law enforcement agency in the country it
says that its main purpose is to quote
find and remove illegal aliens who are
criminals fugitives or recent arrivals
there are 250 detention facilities and
in 2013 I supported a record 438
thousand immigrants the thing is most
detainees who are deported aren't
criminals of those who have been
convicted of a crime almost half were
for nonviolent offenses like traffic
violations or illegally re-entering the
country in fact only 9% of those
deported in 2013 actually qualified as
level one priority as defined by ice I
talked to Rosalee oh who was locked up
in a nice Center for seven months after
being pulled over on his way to work
lava golem a Oreo de las personas la
mayoría de mousse compañeros todos
tenían mal de haar Mucha gente tiene su
snow Stasi hos esposa de su trabajo para
mi principalmente Mexican la familia de
Ferran de muchos formation so why does
ice even lock people up if they're not
criminals well they say detention
ensures that immigrants don't miss their
deportation hearings each detainee cost
taxpayers about one hundred and sixty
one dollars a day
the alternative like remotely monitoring
immigrants cost between 17 cents and
seventeen dollars a day and the
alternatives are still 93% effective in
getting immigrants to appear in court
opponents of detention centers say that
they are worse than prisons while
prisoners get legal counsel and a quick
and speedy trial ice detainees don't in
2013 83 percent of immigrants deported
never even saw a judge detainees report
poor conditions in ice facilities a lack
of medical services allegations of abuse
and
being treated like criminals here an
argument or you talk back to a guard or
something like that you know you work
often you're chained up at all times
around the facility like if you're you
know a killer or some you know you're
chained up on your legs and your feet
you go in segregation so which means you
were in locked up 24 hours a day so how
has it gotten to all this a huge push to
detain and deport immigrants came in
2004 when Iced launched operation
endgame the goal to deport all quote
removable aliens within ten years that
was followed by policies of mandatory
detentions mass fingerprinting and
increasing partnerships between ice and
state and local law enforcement like in
2009 when Arizona passed the law
requiring police to ask for papers from
anyone they suspect don't have them
that's led to not only more deportation
and detentions but open racial profiling
and remember how I said that they're up
to 34,000 dice detainees in any given
time well that's actually a quota that
became law in 2009 critics believe that
that mandate is what is seriously ramped
up to tensions who benefits from these
aggressive policies private companies in
62% of ice detention facilities were run
by private companies the two biggest
ones are CCA and the Geo group the more
detainees there are the more profit and
companies do their fair share of
lobbying Senator Marco Rubio got more
than $27,000 from the geo group in 2013
and that same year Rubio led the gang of
eight in writing immigration reform huh
but it's more than just quotas to fill
and profits to be made we're talking
about people 11 million to be exact with
families jobs and futures so is the
tension in deportation a realistic way
forward for immigration reform and at
what cost
I remember my eyes were like almost
about to cry there is a hint of
embarrassment to be quite honest I
realized that my silence was not
protecting me